we're from ink master and we're gonna be
talking about some celebrity tats just
judging by a lot of the tattoos that Lil
Wayne has he got a lot of them when he
was really young and he just started
getting you know the term was getting
blasted getting as many tattoos as you
can a lot of these tattoos are not about
having quality tattoos it's more about
having a lot of tattoos I myself have a
lot of tattoos that I really cherish
that aren't great works of art they're
more tattoos that I got from friends of
mine the one thing we know about Justin
Bieber is that in all senses he has the
worst taste imaginable so it does not
surprise me at all that every tattoo he
has is completely terrible he's known
for paying tattooers to come to his
house and tattoo him so he can sit
around in his underwear and not have to
go to a tattoo shop we call this
littered with garbage I did not know
that Rihanna had a big crazy hand tat I
think it's better when it's done in
henna because then it goes away I love
mom tattoos I have one it wasn't for
Mama we wouldn't be here so give thanks
to that if his arm is down and this
tattoo is right-side up it's actually a
Wow tattoo if you want your tattoo to
say mom you got to get a face in the
right direction
this is a tattoo done in the traditional
way it's very cool to get this tattoo
done like this when I was in Thailand we
went we found the monks it's a large
risk because the majority of the monks
the way they tattoo is everybody gets
the same tools so there's a big kind of
trust in Health Department over there
and the way that they do it is very
meticulous it's really a very hard thing
to learn and not just anybody can pick
up and do this and to be able to do
these intricate patterns with one needle
takes a really long amount of time and a
heavy amount of enduring pain so she
suffered for this I think this is a
crazy one barring the fact that the guy
got a portrait of himself on his back
it's very steve-o ask but the actual
work itself the portrait that Jack did
is great to get the portrait by Jack
Rudy is a very coveted thing SIBO kind
of making a mockery of it here getting
his own stupid face on there this lion
is a mess getting a little lion portrait
on your fingers is a bad idea and for 25
years
real tattooers have been warning people
against stuff like this because it does
not last or age and if you look at this
photo you can tell you end up with this
this little Turkish mirror on your
finger I mean this line looks like a
lion
you know there's only so much that is
capable in the healing process in the
skin this lion looks like what it's
supposed to get healed it's a nice
tattoo you shrink it down to 1/8 of that
size and put it on the finger it just
doesn't work
this is the purest example of you just
don't care anymore
I think face tattoos for people that are
not fully covered no matter how
permitting the world seems to feel there
are other cultures other places where
you're going to travel and at points
these things could be a hinderance or it
could be a problem
and I understand self-expression I got
tattooed because at the time I wanted to
be rebellious or I wanted to feel a
certain way but getting your face
tattooed without a full bodysuit is a
bit much
[Music]
it's one of Nunez favorite tattoo motifs
in reps with mechanical parts I like any
kind of skin rip I'm in I think they're
great mmm
this is clean you know it has it has
legible shading to it it keeps it open
and can breathe and it fits his forearm
well I was shocked to see Jamie Foxx get
this tattoo I didn't think it was real
at first the thing about this kind of
tattoo is it you know you're a couple
weeks from it not being visible just let
your hair grow out and it goes away I
will say this I'm almost 100% certain
that Chris Brown can afford a better
tattoo than this oof I mean if you pay
this much your tattoos you pay for that
watch he'd be have some nice tattoos
it's a nice watch I like that one that's
funny
this is a perfect example of a party tat
yeah
I have many this is not a quality tattoo
this is not something that you know I
would recommend oh I recommend it there
is a big thing about getting Japanese or
Korean or Chinese or any kind of kanji
written on you that it's a great thing
to get if you want to keep your tattoo
personal to you because it it can be
artistic it can be beautiful it can fit
the body and it can mean whatever it
means to you and you can choose whether
you share with whoever else what this
tattoo means a lot of people over the
last couple decades have gotten tattoos
that they thought said something and
actually said something else anytime
that an american-born person has their
name tattooed on them in any form of
kanji it's wrong it does not say their
name
[Music]
I think this kind of tattoo is very
reminiscent of when people bring in
Crayola drawings of their their young
children and be like my kids are this I
want a tattoo I'm like all right
[Music]